[Music]
[Music]
since the dawn of gaming until the
current day
gamers and game developers alike have
built up a unique lingo to communicate
terminology which describes certain
aspects of game design and mechanics
play styles or in-game objects and often
transcends different cultures and
languages
this kind of terminology is something
people have simply agreed upon over the
many years
sometimes suggested by the game
developers themselves other times by the
community devoted to said games
one such term which most gamers are all
too familiar with
is the dungeon it's a name used to
describe an enclosed maze-like
area commonly filled with puzzles deadly
traps and combat challenges in the form
of hostile npcs
and often times a boss at the end they
are commonly found in rpgs and
action-adventure games
and depending on the genre the goal of a
dungeon may vary but
generally speaking it's a place where
some of the best loot and weapons are
found a great place to grind and in
story-driven games often mandatory to
advance the game's plot the act of
venturing into these dark caverns
treacherous keeps and complex mazes
either alone or with a party is referred
to as a dungeon crawl
like a pub crawl except without beer or
monsters
if you're lucky there's even an entire
genre of games devoted to this concept
alone
like diablo the binding of isaac hades
minecraft dungeons and many more
the word dungeon 2 is just another one
of those names people have agreed upon
even when the game in question doesn't
explicitly refer to it as such
as an example the very first zelda game
from 1986
never refers to its underground
challenges as dungeons specifically
in game they are labeled as levels and
in the manual they are referred to as
labyrinths and yet most people even back
in the day still opted to use the term
dungeon instead the second game in the
franchise zelda 2 the adventure of link
called them palaces
it wasn't until a link to the past that
we find the first use of the word
dungeon in the game's manual to describe
the various temples
caves and keeps link has to overcome and
nowadays the devs working on the zelda
games have fully adopted the term
that being said why do we call them
dungeons
why not trials or mazes or anything else
really this
is a valid question to ask since the
real life equivalent of a dungeon has
little to no correlation with the ones
we encounter in video games
so where did the term come from who
coined it and when did it come to
represent that which we find in modern
video games today
[Music]
the word dungeon actually has quite a
bit of history and misconceptions behind
it
originating from the french word don
john it commonly refers to a room or
cell in which prisoners are held
particularly on the ground however the
original french word actually translates
to something very different
namely keep which is the main tower of a
castle these towers are among the most
fortified parts of the castle and were
used as a refuge of last resort should
the rest of the castle fall to
an adversary and not necessarily for
housing prisoners
in english the definition of a dungeon
seems to have been mixed up with that of
another french word
obliet based on oblie meaning to forget
an obliet is more in line with that
which the english dungeon refers to
a basement room with only one way in and
out usually through a hatch in the
ceiling
initially people assumed that these
underground rooms were used to house
prisoners and were even associated with
torture
but even this turned out to be a
misconception nowadays archaeologists
and scholars of medieval architecture
have since agreed that these
underground basements were primarily
used as a storage space and nothing more
of course this isn't a very exciting
story to tell to a tourist
hence why in some cases tour guides
further perpetuate this misunderstanding
in order to romanticize medieval ruins
this isn't to say that medieval prisons
didn't exist but they were definitely
not as macabre and creepy as the ones we
see in classic fantasy stories
these are in fact pure fantasy and
fiction and were built on the
misconceptions about the middle ages by
18th century scholars and further
perpetuated by novelists in the decades
after
as such the word dungeon evolved to
include prison cells and torture
chambers
giving shape to the classic dark
underground cage-filled room of horrors
as we know them today
obliets and dungeons were a favorite
topic of 19th century gothic novels
where they appeared as symbols of hidden
cruelty or tyrannical power
usually found under medieval castles or
abbeys they were used by villainous
characters to hold their adversaries
prisoner
as soon as film and television made
their debut it adapted the imagery of
the dark prison-like dungeon as
described by fantasy novels to the big
screen
and thus it became a main staple in both
horror and fantasy media it started with
silent films from the 20s and 30s and
even cartoons weighed in on the action
they would show dark medieval-like
environments sometimes even with
treasure laying around in the background
this image of the classic fantasy
dungeon continued all the way into the
60s and 70s
most famously with many of the hammer
films like dracula and frankenstein but
aside from the atmosphere and gothic
aesthetics they still hold little to no
resemblance to that of video game
dungeons as we know them today they are
usually described or depicted as
a singular room with the sole purpose of
locking away unfortunate souls there are
no traps to be found or puzzles to solve
or monsters to fight
the sudden leap from a single room
prison to a challenging
complex labyrinth finds its origins in
the rpg genre
and when i say rpg i don't mean final
fantasy
dragon quests or even the classics like
diablo or ultima
in fact the rpgs we're talking about
aren't even video games
instead we're talking about board games
more specifically
tabletop fantasy role-playing games the
most famous of which
of course being dungeons and dragons
also referred to as dnd
it's debatable whether or not dnd was
the very first of its
kind there was a game named dungeon
exclamation mark which released a year
after dnd in 1975 but is said to have
had a prototype ready as early as 1972.
despite this dnd's publication in 1974
is commonly recognized as the beginning
of modern day role-playing games and the
role-playing game industry
its overall themes are influenced by
world mythology history pulp fiction and
contemporary fantasy novels like lord of
the rings its rules and systems are a
unique blend of different sources
deriving from miniature war games
theater and cinema and various fantasy
novels for the rules and restrictions
involving magic and spells
as is with many board games dnd is not
meant to be played alone the game has a
minimum requirement of two players
though
generally speaking three to six players
is considered to be optimal to provide
the best experience
dnd leans heavily on imagination and can
even be played without the use of pawns
miniatures or even a board or map
although the end goal of an individual
session can vary the game is primarily
centered around traversing an imaginary
world or dungeon
fighting monsters and collecting
treasures one of the defining traits of
dnd is the inclusion of the dungeon
master
an individual who determines the rules
the layout of the environment
monster types locations of treasure and
goals for the other players to
accomplish
essentially the dungeon master is the
equivalent of a video game level
designer as well as acting as a
storyteller or narrator for the
adventure at hand the game set the
standard for many elements we
find in rpgs nowadays things like hit
points and experience points
aka hp and xp character classes
character stats
the list goes on and as such it also
brought the concept of a dungeon as a
labyrinthian challenge rather than a
single room prison into modern day pop
culture
which brings us to video games games did
exist even before d d's release
most notably pong from 1970 which is
considered as the first
commercially successful video game and
the magnavox odyssey the very first
commercially available video game
console ever made
released in 1972 but the medium was
still very much in its infancy around
this time
early video games were mostly based on
physics like tennis games bullets and
asteroids as the popularity of dnd
caught on it didn't take developers long
to realize that the rules and logic of
dnd could easily be translated to actual
code since it was mostly based on
numbers and variables
the earliest video game adaptation of
dungeons and dragons is
again debatable though many point to
pettit 5
as one of if not the first
computer-based dungeon crawler inspired
by the dnd formula
there are talks about a similar game
called m199h
which was said to have existed even
earlier but unfortunately there are no
copies of the game's code in existence
to verify it the story of pettit 5 is
quite interesting
and as you will soon find out
single-handedly created a snowball
effect which led to many of the famous
rpgs we know today
it saw the light of day in 1975 only a
year after dnd's debut and it ran on
plato
an operating system used at the
university of illinois its creator
reginald quote unquote rusty ruthford
was a member of the population and
energy group one of several groups
active at the university each group was
assigned a limited number of program
slots on the school's mainframe which
they were allowed to utilize
the population and energy group had five
which were all named with the prefix
pedit followed by the number
the first three slots were already in
use so rutford used the fifth to code
his game and the fourth for the game's
manual
it uses the basic features of dnd as
much as possible
hit points monster levels experience and
treasure awards and so on the game was
never commercially available and
to make matters worse the university
administrators would often delete it
from the system to save up a memory
inevitably this led to rutford
abandoning the project however it had
become so popular within the university
that others began to take the game's
code and made their own versions this
spawned an entire generation of dnd
inspired games based on pettit 5's core
but with all kinds of revisions
changes and improvements these early
games collectively formed the boundaries
within which
games would develop as video games
entered the 80s
the genre bloomed giving rise to many
dungeon-based rpgs and action-adventure
games like wizardry
ultima the bart's tale mighty magic
megami tensei fantasy star
dungeon master gauntlet and many more
who all helped set the standards for the
genre in the decades to come
both on home computers consoles and even
the arcade
even dnd itself was translated to video
game format multiple times and even a
new installment dungeons and dragons
dark alliance is set for release in 2021
thus we arrive at the current day going
back to
familiar territory for a moment it's
understandable why nintendo initially
didn't use the term dungeon to describe
their underground challenges in the
zelda games
instead calling them levels labyrinths
or palaces zelda wasn't an rpg
after all but although different players
quickly noticed all the similarities to
many other games of its era
self-contained stages separate from the
overworld a place where you primarily
solve puzzles fight monsters and bosses
obtain weapons and items and better
armor even though there are no
experience points involved no party
members
character classes or jobs in terms of
atmosphere and mechanics they are so
similar that players simply started
referring to them as dungeons either way
and nintendo was quick to adapt and
follow the trend set by its fanbase
as the word dungeon became a main staple
in gaming obviously the use of the term
became more and more lenient
nowadays it no longer refers to just a
gothic medieval-style
prison-like maze made of cobblestone
iron bars bones and skeletons they can
represent all sorts of different types
of architecture
atmosphere and aesthetics like caves
mines ancient temples crypts floating
cities
you name it although a more broad
concept nowadays
it's an interesting realization that
something so familiar in video games
which is considered a modern day
invention
finds its origin so far back in time
going from medieval architecture to
early 19th century gothic fantasy novels
to early television to a tabletop board
game which
in turn inspired multiple genres of
video games in the decades after
hey thank you for watching if you liked
this video then
good good good good that makes me happy
what did you expect me to say leave a
like and subscribe
nonsense i don't play by those rules
anyway a big thanks to my patreons and
members who continue to make these
videos possible
also please welcome heist it co-co
laptop account
bedo alexander tash as well as the
return of one of my og patreons
julian clement thank you all so much for
your amazing support
i will see you all next time this is
dawn signing off and okay do please like
and subscribe it really helps
[Music]